mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir encore à la une de l'actualité
les manifestations étudiantes et
lycéennes avec la mort de sept étudiants
la nuit dernière à paris et à ce sujet
on appris il ya quelques minutes que
selon le procureur de la république de
paris
après expertise du corps de marie coup
skins il n'ya pas d'hématomes crâniens
aucune liaison lésions cérébrales et
aucune fracture et trace de violence
observé ne serait pas susceptible
d'avoir entraîné la mort le décès serait
dû à un arrêt cardiaque créé par l'état
pathologique rénale antérieure du
patient cela dit la mort de marie coûts
ce qui n'a suscité une vive émotion et
dans notre région à bordeaux dès 14h cet
après midi a eu lieu une manifestation
spontanée
le reportage de muriel dans guilhem et
jean paul hévin heures quelques jeunes
commencent à se regrouper place de la
victoire
aucune manifestation n'était prévue
c'est par téléphone que certains ont
décidé de se réunir ici cet après-midi
spontanée qui s'est formée et donc par
des contacts téléphoniques des gens qui
se connaissent et c'est tout le monde
est venu manifester
je ne pourrai étaient contre
mende du jeune manifestant mort hier à
travailler les membres du comité de
grève lancé des appels à la population
pour qu'elle se joigne à leur cortège en
direction de la préfecture de région
tous les étudiants ressentent
profondément d'une part de la tristesse
de constater que leur mouvement qui
étaient pacifiques qui souhaitait poser
les problèmes deux ans le gouvernement
tourne comme ça qu'on sent obligé de
constater les mots et quelle est votre
réaction à la suite de la démission de
monsieur jack et je compte que la
démission de monsieur jack et nous est
indifférente
c'était le projet que nous contestions
que le porte parole du projet soit
monsieur jack et qu'il soit monsieur
maurice à nous est indifférent c'est le
projet que vous comptez ce temps nous
demandons le retrait de ce projet est
que 2000 ce sont me suis monory monsieur
chirac qui le défend ne nous est
complètement différent ils sont deux à
trois cents à défiler dans les rues
piétonnes
une marche silencieuse seuls certains
par mégaphone explique que les raisons
de la manifestation
à 17h30 le cortège arrive devant la
préfecture protégée par un cordon de
police l'ordre de dispersion et à leur
donner tout s'est déroulé sans incident
dans le plus grand calme et lune